explosion de joie au stade léon
biancotto l'équipe locale conflent qui
évolue en terrain vient d'éliminer aux
tirs au but aulnésienne une équipe de la
même division
pourtant rien n'a été simple dans ce 5e
tour de coupe de france bousculer les
évitent mois sont menés 2-1 pendant une
grosse partie du match par les joueurs
de seine saint denis on a eu des moments
de flottement l'adversaire et nous
laisser jouer donc un moment donné on
sait pas si on devait accélérer le jeu
de par des passes ou individuellement
donc on a essayé dans un petit peu tous
proposés au final comme d'en sortir
la fin du match est une histoire des
penaltys les joueurs de conflans
égalisent sur ce fait de jeu
score final 2 partout à la fin du temps
réglementaire les yvelinois remporté
ensuite le match lors d'une récente
séance de tirs au but 3 c'était dur ça y
est on est passé c'est un match avec
plein de rebondissements on a su
concrétiser puis à l'eau bout et gagner
la victoire est gagné le match sur une
séquence de matchs avec cette victoire
conflent et le dernier représentant des
yvelines encore en course dans cette
coupe de france 2020 2021 est forcément
l'équipe veut aller le plus loin
possible au stade de france ce sera bien
présente bah le plus loin possible c'est
la cerise sur le gâteau voilà on
continue on fait notre petit bonhomme de
chemin on travaille on est content
d'être ensemble
le 6e tour de la coupe de france est
programmé à partir du samedi 31 octobre
[Applaudissements]